so language is already there as what is
allowing
the acting subject to be able to
conceive what their action is going to
be for others to recognize it you know
robbing a gas station
that happens in language just as much as
it happens in we might say the real
viewer click world
where somebody points a gun at somebody
else and says give me your money says
signifies all of this is happening
within not language itself as in the
there's nothing else there's there's
nothing but language there's a big
difference there's a little bit of a
digression when people were criticizing
derrida for saying there is no outside
of the text right
or text right people got really worked
up about that i remember somebody coming
up to me in graduate school and saying
you think there's nothing but language
everything is language and i looked at
him and i was like
who the hell thinks that
nobody who's doing
linguistically informed philosophy
actually believes that it's all just
language like we're in one sort of you
know
idealistic simulation no the point is
that you're never going to get away from
language because language is already
there doing stuff behind the scenes and
you're using it even to frame the
complaint that you're making that's a
little bit of a
more realistic way of talking about it
hegel is pointing at this right here
right the self that exists that comes
into existence does so through
language language as the existence of
spirit so
so out of the acknowledgement the
recognition again very important term
right we're seeking recognition as
self-consciousness from other
self-consciousnesses we got it before
in this notion of of duty shared across
a community through the medium of
language
so
honor kennen der schraca the
recognition
if we want to play around with this a
little bit yes it could be spoken
acknowledgement the the recognition or
acknowledgement
of language meaning carried out by the
medium of language
it could also mean the recognition
granted
by
the language granted by there being
something bigger than all of us that
were caught up within a language that is
already you could say
moralized and this is so i'm going to go
on a little bit of a digression here
people often
especially if they're coming at language
from a you might say post human
uh
sort of point of view if you know
there's a radical disjunction between is
and ought you know and you can never get
in an audit from an is
they don't realize that the
the you know technically correct
analytic position that they're taking
doesn't map on to the reality of
language as it's been used by human
beings basically as far as we can tell
from from its you know earliest
historical attestations the literature
that we have
language is always carrying but only
imperfectly so moral norms language
provides a space in which morality can
be imposed developed further
applied contested
brought into contradiction with itself
imperfectly expressed that is part of
the nature
of
communication
so
you know i think there's something a bit
bigger going on here than just language
being the
medium in this case
of recognition right
so
and instead what we see as we're
approaching the end of not just this
particular section of spirit but the
entire spirit section
we see a refusal a rejection indeed
a rebellion against spirit by a certain
misunderstanding i was going to say a
certain understanding but really
a certain misunderstanding
of what spirit is on the part of the
judging consciousness we
if we wanted to be a little facetious
here we might not just call it the
judging consciousness in english we
might also call it the judgey
consciousness people are often quite
worried this is a bit of an aside
in ethics classes or intro to philosophy
classes about being you know what they
view as being judgmental and they don't
want to engage in moral judgment
because they're be they're afraid of
being
i won't say the word judged here because
then it gets a little bit convoluted
being ascribe the status of being
judgmental or judgey and one of the
things that's very liberating in ethics
classes is i tell my students hey i
actually want you to be
judgy i want you to be judgmental i want
you to make judgments you just have to
have good bases for doing so and you
have to be willing to have your own
judgments called into question not to
just throw them out there and use them
to elevate yourself above others or to
you know push others away or anything
like that but to genuinely engage others
as human beings and interestingly
we could say coming back to this topic
that is what the acting
consciousness the confessing
consciousness
did in fact do with its confession
you